there is no intrinsic meaning to life
it's not the same thing as saying life
is meaningless you as the
existentialists used to teach you have
to find your project you have to find
out what gets you up in the morning
you have to you have to give your life
meaning
and you have to do it yourself if you
wait for other people to do it and you
know you will leave you will live an
invalid life it won't be your life
you'll be leading other people's lives
and so what is my meaning why do I do
this human beings suffer that's what it
is to be alive is to suffer anything
that a person can do
to alleviate the suffering in others
is a good thing a positive thing a
meaningful thing
stories and do exactly that they make
life livable